good to see you how you doing
i'm doing excellent nice to see you
again as well um so uh i am curious
though which of your friends and family
were the most excited when you told them
that you landed a role in this movie i'm
talking like you know the level you know
what i mean like
got to a level that was just unhealthy
rachel zegler
[Laughter]
um
yeah
yeah i'll go with rachel too
[Laughter]
one of the things that i think that
spiel listen spielberg is a genius we
all know that but but when you look at
west side story specifically the way he
um this the shot selection is so
unbelievable the way he puts the camera
in places that you'd never think to put
it what is it like actually watch
working with someone like that and
watching him
figure out how he's going to shoot it
well like from the time that we're
rehearsing he's also rehearsing and he's
storyboarding and he's coming up with
ideas with janusz as well
some ideas that they don't end up using
some obviously they do and then
also on the day i think he's being
creative as well and coming up with
ideas on the spot but
he always said like you know he's he's
prepared he has his idea and then he
could get rid of get rid of it but he he
has his camera in rehearsal he's filming
us all the time showing us rehearsals
um so yeah it was really cool it was
like we were all kind of preparing
together and we had that long process to
do it so yeah and there was also this
really uh great element too uh where you
wouldn't necessarily know where the
camera was uh you know so we would have
our playground and we would be doing our
thing and our behavior and going through
our motions and all of a sudden be like
okay cut and you're like oh okay moving
on that's it you know so that that was
very like freeing and liberating
when you think uh obviously with
spielberg i'm gonna keep drilling on
this just uh you know i'm kind of a fan
um what what surprised you about working
with him that when you went in you
weren't actually expecting if anything
i guess
he's
no i mean
we you know that how much of a legend he
is you know how how amazing he is uh you
know what he he was a huge fan of
musicals which surprised me like
him actually him and rachel were like
were able to go back and forth with
lyrics from every single
old school movie musical
uh stage musical
like he really knows i mean he he's kind
of like has that encyclopedic knowledge
that some directors kind of like edgar
wright has that too you know of of all
things um entertainment music
uh so that that was pretty surprising
especially the the musical knowledge
i think just like on a personal level
getting to know
him as a human
and uh as an artist and uh
his an infectious child-like joyous
behavior and his approach to what he
does um
just uh
being in that
sphere of joy that he just oozes and you
know it's infectious and wonderful
uh on what day of the shoot did you guys
act like chris farley and just want to
like you know pull him aside and geek
out about
one of his movies
i think mine was day two i i just
started doing it yeah
it was pretty early on
uh
i'm not really a fan of spielberg movies
no no i mean he no he's he's he's a real
good sport and i know a lot the whole
cast was always going crazy about and
he'll he'll play along with the you know
e.t phone home and yeah
yeah i started asking questions so like
immediately well i asked a lot of
questions about daniel day lewis and
stuff so he would he would tell stories
about working with daniel and what do
you tell you
uh for good
they were memorable
but um one of the things i don't think
people realize is what it really takes
to make movies of this scale and scope
and what you have to do to get ready
before standing on set and filming these
huge musical numbers what do you what do
you wish more people knew about making a
musical on this size and scale
well i i i don't know about
everyone else but you know ansel and i
we we had a lot of time to work together
i think like especially for cool um
in between takes having to like keep up
that energy and stuff
and and the animosity that was between
the both of us um and we had been
working on it for like four months up
until this point and i think uh
i don't know we spent you know like 12
hours for three days straight shooting
cool
uh but it was non-stop so in between
takes like he would be off like you know
in his corner
jumping up in the air and keep making
sure that he's continuously out of
breath and focused and doing his thing
and like vice versa yeah we were all but
yeah the energy was always like that and
when we were shooting the rumble and
stuff like everyone's giving 110 every
take everyone between every take is
giving 110 like just leaving nothing on
the table saving nothing yeah uh every
day just going as hard as you possibly
could and that that that energy was
super infectious yeah okay i remember
daniel day-lewis
so
uh stephen was talking about how you
know they're shooting lincoln but he had
played a cobbler before in another movie
and steven had a problem with his shoes
and daniel day lewis was like able to
fix steven's shoes because he was such a
talented cobbler
yeah remember that story what was the
problem with the shoe do you remember
like like maybe you know something was
falling apart or something like this and
he took it and he fixed it for him yeah
and it was during linking lincoln that
he so he was a good sport about it as
lincoln i think he he was able to fix
his shoe
[Laughter]
great story i gotta stop congrats on the
movie i wish you nothing but the best
have a great day
you